this episode is sponsored by keeps we
all know the secret to being an op anime
protagonist is having amazing hair make
me one powerful main character without
hair i'll wait
shut up that's why this episode is
sponsored by keeps keeps is a
subscription service that focuses on
making it easier and more affordable for
men to treat their male pattern baldness
online a licensed doctor will review all
your information online choose the right
treatment plan for you and then ship
that plan right to your door two out of
three men will experience some form of
male pattern baldness in their life so
look to your left
look to your right
if one of those imaginary men sitting
next to you has a full healthy head of
hair
you better watch yourself baby see the
key to all this is prevention if you're
gonna start doing a hundred push-ups 100
sit-ups and 100 squats every day you
better be doing it after you start
taking keeps so what are you waiting for
keep your hair today by clicking the
link in the description or going to
keeps.com
for 50 off your first order that's
k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash giga for 50
off thank you for keep sponsoring us
today let's get on with the video it's
the fall season which means 2021 is
almost over and it's the last season of
anime for the year now this year we've
had some of the best seasons of anime in
history and summer and we've made it
just in time for halloween too so let's
see if there's anything suitable for
that for once hmm we've got
michoacatense nope more 86 nope komi-san
yeah that's a definite note oh wait
miyako-chan all of a sudden a girl is
able to see monsters around her instead
of running away she tries to ignore them
okay this seems pretty creepy let's see
how scary this is
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah i tap that blue period this is
based on a highly acclaimed manga and i
can kind of see why the first episode
sets up story that you can tell is going
to cut deep and hit hard whether you're
into fine art or not i think my favorite
scene in this first episode is when we
see the main character realize his love
for art he fumbles around with the
colors trying to paint his exact vision
of shibuya in the morning he's desperate
to get his image out on paper but gets
frustrated that he lacks the skills to
do so you can see a fiery passion
awakened inside of him he's never cared
about anything else before but this is
what he wants to do he's truly
discovered something new that he loves
in life
and then the guy next to him just goes
this
i'm this guy i actually read the first
volume of the manga ages ago and i
stopped because i was like yeah this is
gonna get an anime adaptation i'm gonna
wait for that and all i can say is that
if this is a faithful adaptation this is
going to be one of the shows to look out
for because from what i've heard and
from what i've read of the manga it is
pure art
eh
eh
hi sir sorry to bother you i'm just
working on the storyboards right now and
uh it's just something very basic to do
with the main girl we've got this scene
coming up and i just wanted to know how
you wanted it to be framed
pointed out our ass
as much as i'm enjoying this i'm getting
very confused as to how the show wants
me to feel i get the vibe that this is
meant to be a horror comedy i like the
concept and it's certainly entertaining
seeing a poor innocent girl trying her
best to ignore terrifying ghosts and
monsters but then on top of that the
entire thing seems hornier than a
gentian player looking up ganyu fan art
which i guess shouldn't be surprising
coming from the studio that gave us men
of culture the animation but what really
throws me off is that the ghosts are
genuinely unnerving like the scary bits
are actually scary it has better horror
than most horror anime but then it cuts
off to some chord in 4k unreal 5 high
definition render off some girls camel
toe honestly though i'm going to keep
watching because i do think it's
original take and i think it's
definitely enjoyable seeing her try to
deal with all these different
aberrations coming at her
bang bang bang bang bang bang bang bang
do you ever look back at the cold war
era space race and think to yourself
anyone else feel dismissing vampires we
got definitely not the soviet union
competing with off around america to do
good for their glorious nation by
sending the first vampire into space and
i mean this is certainly a unique
concept but i've said this before but
i'm just not a fan of vampires
[Music]
like i was saying i'm a big fan of any
stories with vampire is this a cute
tsundere with a top-tier pout face and a
smug face to boot yo yo yo yo yo stop
stop stop guys guys guys stop trying to
claim her new waifu okay stop
she's our rifle i like this one yes okay
it's because of the sun's ray alright
you got me but like how can i not i mean
you know what sunderies be like
[Music]
you know when i hear about some new ip
anime getting made that's meant to
promote some upcoming mobile game i was
like
wake me up when the real shit's coming
out but then you see a scene like this
[Music]
and then you're just like oh
oh okay this is some main monitor [ __ ]
you know i've forgotten how hard mad
house would go with some help from
mapper of course but gorgeous animation
aside i just love the [ __ ] designs
and aesthetics of this show with a quiet
place-esque world filled with monsters
attracted to music superhumans fight
back with abilities that use the power
of classical music set in the backdrop
of america it's such a mishmash of
bizarre ideas it just works this is one
of those shows that drags you in with
the rule of cool and i'm just a sucker
for anything that uses music as one of
the core aspects of the show so i'm
definitely excited to see where this one
goes oh hell yeah mecha fans be eating
good this year i mean just look at this
sunrise are finally going back to their
roots see call me old-fashioned but i
like my mix like i like my woman
2d what god it feels so long since we've
seen just traditional 2d mechs from a
new original mech ip coming from sunrise
even if here they've essentially just
made code geass double o alright i'm
just being facetious i mean yes you do
have a japan that's been conquered where
citizens are all treated as sub-human
and it's all up to a single and probable
young boy to save the nation but
remember code gear started off with them
joining a resistance terrorist
organization but this is nothing like
that look they even say sorry
okay well i know this looks bad but
we're not fighting or anything
all right well that was just
self-defense we're not going out there
blowing [ __ ] up
i'll just play the [ __ ] code gears
theme
you know when you get this feeling about
a show that even if the general
consensus is that it's not the standout
show of the season it might just be your
standout show of the season well that's
sakugan for me sakiyan is a massively
underwatched show about a
father-daughter ragtag duo on a grand
adventure in the depths of a labyrinth
world filled with kaiju piloting a mecca
to help a human civilization that's
trapped underground if this sounds kind
of like made in lagaan with a side of
decadence you'd be absolutely right but
what really drew me in and what makes it
stand out to me is the main duo
sometimes you just see characters that
instantly click their chemistry was an
instant sale for me and after a single
episode i was already dangerously
invested in their relationship [ __ ] this
season's best girl we found best
daughter it was fun it was charming it
was emotional amplified by the bombastic
osc because my god does the music kick
[ __ ] ass
there are a few things that are rough
around the edges the cg looks jank and
the hype scenes aren't on the same
master class level you'd find on
something like a trigger show i can see
why this didn't immediately stand out to
the wider crowd but i feel such a strong
heart behind it out of everything i've
watched this one is the one that put the
biggest smile on my face and i know that
if it's able to hit the marks i think it
can hit this is gonna be one of my
favorites of this season i don't know
guys i've just got a really good feeling
about this one next one we have shh
it's easy kai time mishoku tensei
continues to have one of the most
impressive productions for an isakai
anime tv series i've seen though if
you're looking for something in the same
vein the faraway paladin is a new show
that seems to have the same thoughtful
approach to the world building and
characters without the horny in a show i
can best describe as if dark souls
characters had a slice of life spin-off
restaurant another world got another
season
that's my notes we've got some guy who
opens up a drugstore in another world in
the most unique concept we've ever seen
in an isikai since last season's
drugstore
in another world there's an isakai
starring a main character who is and i
quote an ugly revolting dirty smelly fat
ass made by an animation studio called i
share you not feel children's playground
did the edp 455 make a [ __ ] eso car
from the creators of death note we've
got plan the mend featuring incel light
yagami taking part in some divine death
game where the winner gets to become god
whatever that means this looks like some
edgy fun seems like it's gonna have the
same kind of over-the-top deep thinking
mind games we've seen in death note
except this time there's a cute kawaii
angel who seems a bit too trigger happy
with the idea of murdering people we
don't know who the rest of the god
candidates are yet but i mean they've
already given us a glimpse of everyone
we need to look out for so you know what
i'm going to get ahead of the curve
let's put our detective hats on and see
what we got to worry about hmm all right
we've got a spiky head guy a teenager an
adult
a child
a schoolgirl
a
man i have three words for you
john wick insecure if you're getting
bored of the usual epic game and nerd
protagonist gets easy guide and suddenly
becomes a sigma male then let me
introduce you to this we've got the
world's greatest assassin who dies and
gets hired by an isukai goddess to
reincarnate so he can assassinate the
hero of the fantasy world this is
honestly got a really interesting take
on the genre and it's just so refreshing
to see a main character who was actually
a badass before he got issac for once
it's where to see nisakai where the
guy's life before is just as interesting
as his life after he got reincarnated
and you know for such a refreshing take
on the usual easter guy protagonist i
wonder what kind of genius came up with
this
oh
i've made a severe
and continuous lapse in my judgment oh
yeah baby say goodbye to sassy barker
and say hello
to cheeky senpai
oh get all this stick with splitter in
half and then there's ranking of kings
now i'm gonna be absolutely honest i
completely looked over this one because
well
it looks like a kids show okay but you
should enjoy the book by its cover you
know i know i know but shut up okay i'm
not the biggest fan of the art style the
world is very ghibli-esque which is
something that doesn't appeal much to me
so in an anime season where i barely
have time to watch all the good shows
this [ __ ] matters and i say this because
in spite of all this in spite of all my
preconceptions this to me was one of the
most impressive anime this season in a
world where kings are ranked and their
strengths inspire a nation you have a
weak
and mute prince who aspires to be the
world's greatest king in spite of all
those in his kingdom doubting him it's a
simple tale that is propped up by great
writing and some of the best
storytelling you can find this season i
came in watching it to take off a box
and i went out almost crying because of
the backstory of this black [ __ ] blob
with eyes i don't know what the [ __ ]
this is i would say that a lot of this
is because studio wets are just on fire
right now but i mean like when the [ __ ]
aren't they i'm not sure if these
[ __ ] are capable of missing because
they've somehow given us yet another
banger
word around the offices you've got a fat
[ __ ] as the veritable waifu flavor of
the month komi-san was one of the most
anticipated adaptations this season and
if you don't keep up with the manga
scene you may be thinking all right
what's so special about this waifu
that's got everyone up in arms well you
see comey
is afraid of social interaction
i knew that i put komi-san in the
category i like to call discord profile
picture manga you know the type of manga
i swear to god is made to appeal to the
type of people who still laugh at the
number 69. so i
nice so i gotta be completely honest i
came into this thinking i'm better than
this as the self-proclaimed tsundere
loving shitlord i was i wasn't gonna be
charmed by this girl i mean what's she
gonna do quietly exhale on me you think
i'm gonna fall for the waifu version of
heavy breathing cats but god damn it i
can't man she's just too damn adorable
we've had a fair share of socially
awkward hashtag relatable introverts am
i right kind of shows but this is the
first time i've seen someone with
crippling social anxiety not only that
but this is the best animation i've seen
for a slice of life show outside of
kyoto animation i mean some of these
shots look straight up film quality this
is looking like it's going to be one of
the most wholesome feel-good shows of
the year because for real knowing a lot
of people with social anxiety i'm really
glad something like this exists there
are so many people out there who want to
open up but don't have the courage or
know how to do so and even in this first
episode seeing just a glimpse of someone
taking that first step of trying to open
up just melted my heart immediately and
made me hope that someday i could help
someone too take that first step
next
bye
hey guys hope you enjoyed the video
thank you to keeps for sponsoring me
today and also thank you very much to
alpha sigma basil dysfunctional
degenerate elephant ivido jeff levardos
manopla payne patchett pony stark walto
and everyone else my patreon for helping
to support me this month as you can see
i'm filming from the trash taste office
right now because my new home is an
absolute state which is the best way i
can describe it because um it kind of
looks like a nuclear bomb just got set
off in there right now so yeah i'm still
setting everything up in my new home so
luckily i do have a office to work in so
it looks like by november time we should
be back on our normal schedule i know
people are just like ah
old giga has returned it's monthly
uploads once again anyway though that's
pretty much all the updates i've had i'm
gonna go back to building a [ __ ] ton of
furniture right now so hope you enjoyed
the video i've been gigguk and i'll see
you all next time